it's a beautiful feeling you're in the
water you're chasing down your prey and
shooting hit with a spirit rather than
casting a lion and reeling it in that
feeling hasn't changed since the first
ancient Chamorro caught his first fish
in the first two parts of this series we
learned how Guam became a modern-day
colony and about the fight for
independence in this part we'll meet a
young Indigenous couple who's trying to
liberate Guam through food everything we
do is centered around that respect that
we have furniture we revolve around
nature Nature doesn't revolve around us
this is Francesca and Helen they're
working to make guam's diet less
dependent on imported food this is my
mom and dad's garden where I grew up we
grew up here in this house this fern is
actually called call out it's used
intramural medicine as a tea so you just
pick the leaf and you boil it in water
and then you can use the steam to clear
your sinuses it works better than
eucalyptus there's really alarmingly
high rates of cancer in our community as
along with other lifestyle diseases
which happened because of colonialism
and because of the environmental and
justices that I've been brought upon our
island preserving our land preserving
our way of life is to protect ourselves
protect our bodies protect our children
and our our communities because we're
dying on Guam the rate of diabetes is
twice as high as the rest of the u.s. in
2014 half of the deaths on the island
were due to heart disease and cancer
obesity and diabetes and all of these
diseases and all these ailments which
didn't really exist before suddenly
they're overtaking the culture
this was a community that relied on
farming and fishing we didn't have
grocery stores on Guam foods came from
your farm and yer and fishing and
hunting this continued through Spanish
colonization and even when the US Navy
first took control the islands and began
stripping tommorow's of their land but
during World War two when the Japanese
occupied the island there wasn't enough
food to go around and when the Americans
came back at the end of the war they
took almost two thirds of the land on
Guam the Second World War was like a
huge shock to the island culturally
suddenly thousands of people don't have
land anymore people who farmed their
entire lives and provided for themselves
suddenly have to work wage jobs so when
the military took that land for them
they completely took away their entire
means of subsistence by 1944 the
Chamorro farming way of life had pretty
much disappeared and people were
starving they needed an alternative
solution how do you feed an entire
islands population instantly well it was
through canned food and spam so spam
becomes part of the diet and their
tomorrows who view spam very emotionally
like when they see a kind of spam they
they'll get choked up and it reminds
them of the Marines and a freedom
unfortunately it coincides with them now
losing their ranches so now becoming
reliant on this diet of press
foods poor diet isn't the only health
problem on Guam high rates of cancer are
also attributed to contamination by the
herbicide Agent Orange which was used as
a weapon during the Vietnam War and
according to testimonies was also used
at the time to kill plant overgrowth on
Guam Guam is also downwind of the
Marshall Islands where the US military
tested nuclear bombs for 12 years you're
in the water with the fish you only
catch one fish at a time but you get to
choose exactly which fish it is so you
know that you're not getting a fish
that's not mature you get the ones that
are too small then they don't have a
chance to reproduce fish for the next
fishermen or for you for next time when
you are reliant on your resources when
you when you fish every day yeah when
you eat and live off of the land then
you're more conscious of the impact that
you have on the land and the ocean and
that's something that is it already
instill it its inherent in Shamar
culture there's only you know so many
islands that we can say that we come
from and you can find the Chamorro
people or culture anywhere else in the
world
dining angers the fence like the back
thanks to beam us may be based here and
want the families that used to occupy
this land before the war we're forced
out of it after the war so that the u.s.
can build a Navy base this fish is a
pair of fish this is called Paluxy and
tomorrow he'll actually means slippery
it's the best fish in the ocean
the original Chamorro diet was made up
of lots of fish bananas
breadfruit even fruit bats but over the
years the influence of other cultures
introduced foods like lumpia from the
philippines red rice made with hota seed
brought in by the spanish and of course
spam
yeah this is a fried pirate fish okay
this is breadfruit cooked in coconut
milk I didn't like fish didn't like
coconut milk because they didn't grow up
with it I didn't like it what was in
your household growing up canned food it
she bad ramen instant ramen noodles
that's why the therapist heart disease
in our family and we're so proud of the
fact that we're like number two seconds
in Hawaii and the consumption of spam
yeah cook-offs
teriyaki spam garlic's perhaps by c-span
the penis bands by Machine the stores
during Christmas they do it's bad
Christmas tree installations and food
you buy from the store is not cheap I
was like nine dollars for a gallon of
milk
seven dollars eight dollars and butter
and why it's blue to the Jones Act
importing the Jones Act says that only
US ships can transport goods between US
ports making shipping really expensive
to places like Puerto Rico Hawaii and
Guam and because ninety percent of the
food here is imported that additional
cost is a real burden for the people who
live on the island why do you guys find
it so important to build a movement
around sustainable food we've been so
indoctrinated to believe that our
resources come from somewhere else but
they're here they're here they've always
been here our food independence
is our political independence it isn't
the one thing most people are afraid of
losing it was incredibly inspiring to
meet so many young tomorrow's who are
reclaiming their food traditions and
culture with the history of colonization
occupation and militarization tomorrow
people on Guam have been stripped of so
much of their land traditions and
autonomy but they continue to survive
and some are determined to take back
their island altogether hey guys I want
to introduce you to our incredibly
talented animator Marissa half-a-day I'm
tomorrow so working on this series meant
a lot to me please share with your
friends and don't forget to subscribe to
untold America